momento de actualizar la información
económica en france 24 y por ello le doy
la bienvenida a mi compañero luís méndez
luis iniciamos en eeuu porque la cámara
de representantes aprobó la extensión
del límite de deuda una noticia que se
acaba de producir en ese país y esta
aprobación será por un corto periodo de
tiempo es decir hasta el próximo mes de
diciembre del presente año y evitará que
la nación caiga en incumplimientos de
pago por primera vez el proyecto ahora
se ha enviado el presidente joe biden
que deberá firmarlo y promulgar lo la
cámara voto 219 a 206 en favor del
proyecto que fue aprobado por el senado
la semana pasada este amplíe el techo de
deuda hasta los 480 mil millones de
dólares y de acuerdo con la publicación
estadounidense de 100 peace y la deuda
nacional actual de esas naciones de 28.4
billones de dólares y gracias a la
iniciativa podrá aumentar hasta los 28.8
millones de totales louis y ahora
pasamos a las previsiones de crecimiento
tras el informe del fondo monetario
internacional
hay que destacar que este informe
desprende una situación de caídas
moderadas dentro de la economía mundial
para lo que resta de año esto en
comparación con el informe presentado en
el mes de julio el organismo con sede en
washington advierte que la recuperación
económica mundial se ha visto afectada
por varios factores entre ellos las
interrupciones en la cadena de
suministro en los países
industrializados y la disparidad en
cuanto a las tasas de vacunación en
varias naciones del mundo en este
sentido el fondo monetario internacional
rebajó el crecimiento mundial a 59 por
ciento tan sólo una décima menos que el
informe presentado en julio del presente
año cuando la ubicó en 6% pero éste dijo
jim a opinar economista jefe del
organismo el momento de presentar el
informe
el campo
comparado con nuestro informe de julio
la proyección de crecimiento global para
este año se ha revisado a la baja
marginalmente a 59 por ciento y no ha
cambiado para el 2022 de glover y
cambridge la recuperación mundial
continúa pero el impulso se ha
debilitado por la pandemia y una
variante del está altamente transmisible
de alce ver bien en cuanto a las
economías de américa latina las
perspectivas de crecimiento en algunos
países también mostraron variaciones
destaca el caso de argentina que estima
según el organismo un crecimiento de 7.5
por ciento esto es poco más de la
previsión que estimó el gobierno en
agosto pasado además el caso de chile
ubicó en 11 por ciento del crecimiento
para este año louis y ahora pasamos otra
vez a eeuu porque se dio a conocer el
resultado de un nuevo informe del
departamento de trabajo así es y este
informe revela que durante el pasado mes
de agosto las renuncias aumentaron a 43
millones dentro de las 6 millones de
separaciones de puestos de trabajo que
se habían registrado en este período la
situación se presenta como una
consecuencia al miedo que presentan los
ciudadanos edad productiva a ser
contagiados por la variante delta y
ahora pasamos a chile porque se debate
sobre un cuarto retiro del 10% del fondo
de pensiones cuentas aunque los
parlamentarios esperan llevar la
iniciativa a votación durante la última
semana del mes de octubre el banco
central de ese país ha mostrado
desacuerdos en contra de la iniciativa
el retiro va a tener un costo para el
fisco la acumulación va a tener un costo
mayor que todo el paquete tributario que
se está proponiendo lo dijo el
presidente del banco central mario
marcel este martes la medida ha sido una
propuesta para disminuir el impacto de
la pandemia en los hogares chilenos y
permitió una temprana reactivación de la
economía y ahora vamos con paraguay o
con uruguay mejor existe la preocupación
por la falta de personal para la
apertura de fronteras como es eso
estamos hablando del personal de aduanas
y la preocupación surge tras un informe
presentado por el diario 'el observador'
de ese país que cita a la asociación de
funcionarios aduaneros de acuerdo con el
organismo y el citado diario entre 2010
y la actualidad la cantidad de
funcionarios pasos de 1800
130 la situación de acuerdo con la nota
generará dificultades para el control
del tráfico sobre los puentes vamos a
conocer los indicadores louis los
indicadores cerraron de manera negativa
en eeuu sobre todo porque existe el
nerviosismo en cuanto a la temporada de
informes trimestrales en europa también
se dieron cierres negativos a lo largo
de la jornada todo ello por el temor a
que la inflación genere un rápido alivio
que lo que s los fondos para la
recuperación económica el mercado
japonés inició ya operaciones con
números positivos y nuestra cifra del
jazz tiene que ver en este caso con los
12 mil millones de euros que fueron
recaudados en la primera venta de bonos
verdes de la unión europea para lograr
la recuperación o el financiamiento para
la recuperación económica esos países
louis muchas gracias por la información
económica de ustedes también muchas
gracias por sintonizarnos quédense con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]